So the Game of Thrones show is based off a
really long series of books.
Longer than The Lord of the Rings and the
Bible combined – and the series hasn’t
even all been written yet.
So to fit this huge story into seventy-three
hours of TV, the show cuts out a lot of characters
and plots from the books, which kinda sucks,
cause a lot of them are really cool and mysterious
– for example, the story of Gerion Lannister.
The Lannisters we meet in the show include
Tywin – father of Cersei, Jaime and Tyrion
– and Tywin’s brother Kevan – father
of Lancel, Martyn and Willem.
But in the books, Tywin has three more siblings
– there’s Genna Lannister, a smart, domineering
woman married to a Frey, and Tygett Lannister,
a skilled warrior who died of a pox years
ago, and then there’s Gerion.
Gerion was Tyrion and Jaime’s favourite
uncle growing up . He taught Tyrion to tumble,
to cartwheel and walk on his hands , and encouraged
him to learn about the wonders of the world
. This was in contrast to the eldest Lannister
Tywin, always so stern and serious . Tygett
and Gerion felt they were in Tywin’s shadow,
but while Tyg got angry that he could never
match Tywin, Gerion would make a joke of it
all – “Better to mock the game than to
play and lose” . So Gerion travelled the
east , he competed in tournaments , he fathered
a bastard daughter, Joy, by a common woman,
Briony . And then about seven years before
the start of the main story, Gerion went on
a quest to find House Lannister’s lost Valyrian
steel sword, Brightroar .
So Valyrian steel is a magical metal , made
in Valyria centuries ago.
It was used to make weapons, like swords,
that were sharper, stronger and lighter than
swords of regular steel . But when Valyria
blew up, in the Doom, the secret of making
the steel was lost . Now, there are only a
couple of hundred Valyrian steel blades left
in Westeros . Many of them are treasured as
the heirlooms of noble houses – for example,
Heartsbane is the Valyrian blade of House
Tarly, and Longclaw was the sword of House
Mormont until Jeor gave it to Jon Snow – in
the show, Jon discovers Valyrian steel can
kill white walkers , which is another reason
it’s important.
Brightroar was once the Valyrian blade of
House Lannister – they paid a huge amount
of gold for in the years before the Doom . But
about a century later, after Valyria was destroyed,
King Tommen Lannister went on an expedition
to plunder the ruins of Valyria.
He took Brightroar with him – and “never
returned” . So Brightroar, one of House
Lannister’s most valuable treasures, was
lost, and ever since, they’ve tried to replace
it.
Tywin offered to buy Valyrian swords from
poorer houses, but was always refused . So
Gerion, the more adventurous, or perhaps just
“reckless” Lannister , decided to go find
Brightroar himself, where Tommen lost it centuries
ago – in the ruins of Valyria .
Valyria was once the capital of a prosperous,
powerful empire, but after its mysterious
destruction, a smoking broken ruin remains.
In the show, Tyrion and Jorah sail through
it like it ain’t no thang, but in the books,
Valyria’s cursed.
It’s said the very sea there boils and smokes,
the land is overrun with demons, and anyone
who “lays eyes upon [its] coast is doomed”
. Whole armies have marched into Valyria and
never returned . But that didn’t stop Gerion.
He set sail from Lannisport, and headed for
Valyria . When he stopped off at Volantis,
half his crew deserted him, and he had to
buy slaves to replace them, cause everyone
was so scared of sailing the Smoking Sea . After
Volantis, Gerion disappeared – and was never
seen again.
So… what happened?
There are lots of different theories.
The most obvious one is that Gerion died in
Valyria.
We don’t know exactly what the dangers of
Valyria are, whether they’re toxic volcanic
fumes, or demons, or magic, but there’s
clearly something nasty there, cause it’s
killed so many people before – Gerion’s
ancestor Tommen included.
Gerion might also have been shipwrecked, attacked
by pirates, or killed in a mutiny of his crew.
However it happened, it’s a likely explanation
– that Gerion is dead and won’t be seen
again.
But there are other theories.
Not everyone who’s sailed to Valyria has
died – Euron Greyjoy claims to have been
there , and it looks like he’s telling the
truth, cause in the books he has a Valyrian
dragon horn , and a set of Valyrian steel
armour . If Euron has been to Valyria, and
Gerion apparently died there, maybe Euron
and Gerion ran into each other, maybe Euron
killed or captured Gerion, maybe Gerion is
one of the mute oarsmen on Euron’s ship
the Silence – but… this is unlikely because
of the timelines – Gerion sailed for Valyria
about eight years ago , but Euron went on
his big voyage about two years ago – so
unless Gerion was hanging around in Valyria
for six years, he wouldn’t have met Euron
there . Another theory is that Gerion became
the “corsair king”, a pirate who’s been
mentioned raiding round the Summer Isles,
but again, the timeline doesn’t fit.
The corsair king is “new” , only recently
started raiding, so if the corsair is Gerion,
what was he doing these last eight years?
One of the crazier theories is that Gerion
is the Shrouded Lord, a mysterious mystical
figure who lives in the Sorrows, which Tyrion
passes through in Dance.
YouTuber Preston Jacobs argues that the Lord
seems to spare Tyrion from getting greyscale
from stone men , that both Gerion and the
Shrouded Lord are associated with laughter
, and that the Lord must look like Gerion
because Tyrion dreams of the Lord being Tywin
. It’s a fun idea, but the text doesn’t
really support it.
The dream has nothing to with Gerion, the
laughter connection is barely mentioned in
the text, and the Lord sparing Tyrion is tenuous
at best.
To complicate things some more, it is mentioned
that this “corsair king” supposedly is
the current Shrouded Lord – shit’s most
assuredly confusing and complex, but in the
end, there’s just no good evidence that
Gerion is the Shrouded Lord or the corsair
king, or anybody else.
Not every missing character has a twist and
a secret identity – Gerion probably is just
dead in Valyria – but there’s still another
theory to address.
It’s about a woman called the Sailor’s
Wife, a prostitute in Braavos who only beds
the men who marry her in fun little temporary
wedding ceremonies . The Sailor’s Wife has
a daughter, called Lanna , who has “fine
long golden hair” . Blonde hair and the
name Lanna make the girl sound like a Lannister
, right?
And we hear that the Sailor’s Wife prays
for “her first husband, her true husband”,
“her old love”, “who had been lost at
sea” . Maybe the Sailor’s Wife’s “first
husband”, and the father of her blonde daughter
Lanna, is Gerion Lannister.
Gerion was “lost at sea”, that’s the
exact phrase consistently used to describe
him . And Gerion would explain Lanna’s blonde
hair and name.
Further, the fortune-teller Yna , claims that
the Sailor’s Wife’s husband is dead – which
fits the idea that Gerion died in Valyria.
So this seems like pretty strong theory but
again – the timing’s tricky.
Lanna is fourteen in the fourth book , which
means she was fathered years before Gerion
sailed to find Brightroar, which is fine,
cause we know he travelled the east before,
but remember Gerion’s daughter Joy?
She is eleven in the fourth book . Which means
for Gerion to have fathered both Joy and Lanna,
he must have sailed to Braavos, married the
Sailor’s Wife and fathered Lanna, then left
and just two years later fathered Joy on Briony
in Westeros – and a few years after that
sailed to Valyria and died.
Which is… possible, but seems weird.
It totally undercuts the whole tragic love
story of the Sailor’s Wife if her long lost
husband actually just dumped her and left
to hook up with someone else.
Also, the Sailor’s Wife was “no older”
than fourteen when her husband left, and she
and her child both work as prostitutes to
support themselves.
Why would Gerion not send a little Lannister
gold their way at some point?
Joy seems to be pretty well supported – why
treat the Sailor’s Wife differently?
Tyrion’s favourite uncle doesn’t sound
like the sorta guy to so coldly abandon a
loving wife and child.
So what gives?
The might be a solution in the timing.
While writing the fourth Game of Thrones book,
George Martin planned to leave a “five-year
gap” between the third and fourth books,
meaning Book 4 would pick up the story five
years after the third, with all the characters
five years older – Arya would have spent
five years training with the Faceless Men,
Bran would have been learning from Bloodraven
– but Martin found the gap didn’t work
so well for other characters, so after a year
of writing with the gap, he scrapped it, and
instead had Book 4 pick up where Book 3 ended
. This meant he had to go back and re-write
a lot of what he’d already written, changing
stuff to remove the gap.
He would have had to change details like dates
and years and… ages.
The five-year gap made everyone five years
older, so to remove the gap from what he’d
already written he’d have to make some characters
five years younger and maybe – just maybe
– he made a mistake – and forgot to change
back the age of Lanna.
Because if Lanna was five years younger, she’d
be nine instead of fourteen, which would mean
she could have been conceived the same year
that Gerion sailed for Valyria.
Which changes everything.
Instead of Gerion having to sail to Braavos,
marry then dump the Wife, go back to Westeros,
father Joy, then sail to Valyria, he could
have just stopped off in Braavos and met the
Wife along the way to Valyria – with every
intention of coming back to her – until
he was tragically “lost at sea”, leaving
the Wife and Lanna longing, never knowing
if he’d return.
That fits the tragic story of the Sailor’s
Wife much better, and the math works perfectly
– Lanna’s fourteen in Feast, minus five
for the gap makes nine, so she’d be born
in the year 291.
Gerion sailed eight years before Storm, which
happens in 299, so he sailed in about 291.
It looks very very possible that George Martin
made a small mistake with Lanna’s age.
So Gerion probably didn’t meet Euron.
He probably isn’t a corsair, or the Shrouded
Lord.
He’s probably a corpse somewhere in Valyria
– which is all the more tragic cause it
looks like he left behind a child and a Wife
who love him, who he may have meant to return
to until he sadly died.
And you almost wouldn’t know it cause it
may be George forgot to do some math.
Thanks for watching.
Some of these images come from The World of
Ice and Fire, which you can buy at the link
below.
This Gerion art is by kethryn on DeviantArt,
and this Euron art is by Evaun Wallington,
find him on Twitter.
Thanks to the Patrons for making this video
possible, including William Horner, A.K.
Chawla, Rachel Ober, scot jennings, and Persephone
Jones.
Cheers.